[Música]
el mundo entero lo veía a través de
televisión o de los principales medios
de comunicación y muchos no lo podían
creer las tropas de Estados Unidos y sus
aliados internacionales entraron a Irak
para una lucha frontal contra el
presidente iraquí Sadam hussein que dio
paso a una Sangrienta guerra que vino la
seguridad de la región y que también se
saldó con la muerte de hussein llevó a
una transición política llegó al
supuesto fin de esa amenaza
Internacional del terrorismo y también
prometía una ansiada estabilidad en la
región quienes hicieron parte de esta
guerra lo vemos en el siguiente informe
que preparó la redacción de France 24
son imágenes de hace 20 años que pasaron
a la historia después de este anuncio
del entonces presidente de Estados
Unidos George Bush en este momento las
fuerzas estadounidenses y de la
coalición se encuentran en las primeras
fases de las operaciones militares para
desarmar Irak liberar su pueblo y
defender el mundo de un grave peligro
una invasión que dio inicio una cruenta
guerra en el país que se extendió hasta
2011 y se saltó con la vida de cientos
de miles de civiles pero Cuáles son los
principales actores armados Estados
Unidos y la coalición grupo de países
que apoyaron militarmente o
políticamente la invasión fueron uno de
los principales actores Durante los ocho
años que estuvieron en el país
derrocaron al gobierno de Sadam hussein
pusieron a un ejecutivo Chita Aliado en
el poder y fueron acusados de crímenes
de guerra y violaciones a los Derechos
Humanos el gobierno era aquí combatió a
Los Invasores pero atrás del
derrocamiento de hussein Estados Unidos
lo desmantelo por ser de mayoría sunita
y colocó a soldados citas Con escasa
preparación y malos resultados un batido
frente al que surgieron las milicias
iraquíes para plantarle cara a la
coalición en especial destaca el
conocido como ejército de almagy que
comparó a Estados Unidos con una
serpiente y mató a muchos de sus
soldados en 2004 los grupos terroristas
también han desempeñado un rol central
en el conflicto desde al qaeda hasta la
autodenominado estado islámico nacido en
Irak y derivado de la corriente sunita
fundamentalista ambas formaciones
consideraban al régimen exiíta e iraquí
como ilegítimo y querían devolver al
poder a los sunitas con La retirada de
Estados Unidos del país en 2011
aprovecharon el vacío de poder y Se
tomaron un tercio del país también hay
un espacio reservado para los
patchmergas o kurdos históricamente han
reivindicado tierras del Norte del país
tensiones con el gobierno iraquí por lo
que se aliaron con Estados Unidos y
occidente y tuvieron un papel
fundamental en la caída de husein aunque
aún no han conseguido la tan anhelada
Independencia 20 años después con el
conflicto supuestamente atrás aún hay
grupos armados que generan gran
inestabilidad en Irak tanto es así que
en 2014 el presidente Obama tuvo que
enviar a 2500 tropas para asistir al
ejecutivo iraquí que aún siguen allí con
la promesa de estabilidad muy lejos en
el Horizonte
20 años después la invasión y guerra en
Irak es vista de diferentes formas en la
comunidad internacional desde vergüenza
y rechazo hasta satisfacción en algunos
casos los argumentos para justificarla
Como por ejemplo la supuesta posesión de
armas de destrucción masiva por parte de
Sadam hussein pues fueron desmentidos
muchos años después la invasión fue
llevada a cabo también sin tener un
permiso de la Organización de Naciones
Unidas y que dejó pues como lo veíamos
un país dividido un estado incapaz de
hacer frente a los retos que se le
presentan un descontento social que
encontró alivio en cierta manera en el
islam radical una sociedad fragmentada
también un estancamiento económico en
uno de los mayores productores de
petróleo en el mundo y la tan anhelada
Paz estabilidad y democracia Pues bien
gracias se quedó en eso en una promesa
que todavía 20 años después los iraquíes
siguen esperando hoy en el debate de
France 24 Irak 20 años después Cuáles
fueron las lecciones aprendidas para
hablar sobre este tema hemos invitado a
Andrés de Castro García él es
subdirector del instituto universitario
general Gutiérrez mellado Andrés se
encuentra en la ciudad de Bogotá en
Colombia y desde San Sebastián en el
norte de España se conecta José Antonio
Ejido él es analista internacional
doctor en sociología por la universidad
de provenza Marsella le recuerdo a los
televidentes que ustedes también hacen
parte de este debate de esta discusión
pueden dejar todo tipo de comentarios y
preguntas a través de las redes sociales
ya las conocen estamos en Twitter en
Facebook También estamos en instagram en
donde nos encuentran como arroba
franz24_s la etiqueta para que dejen los
comentarios es numeral el debate f24
todo pegado todo junto y a mí me
encuentran en Twitter como arroba
santilogo no olviden también que todos
los contenidos de nuestro programa están
disponibles en Apple podcast en Spotify
en deezer y en TuneIn
comienzo entonces dándole la bienvenida
Andrés en la ciudad de Bogotá Andrés
gracias por estar con nosotros en el
programa y la pregunta básica para hacer
balance de lo que deja o dejó esta
invasión esta guerra en Irak 20 años
después como titulamos el programa Qué
lecciones dejó Cuáles su análisis
bienvenido
muchísimas gracias y buenas tardes las
lecciones principales que sacamos es
precisamente el error que ha sido que en
el momento en el que Estados Unidos
encontraba con mucha capacidad política
lo que los profesores de relaciones
internacionales llamamos el momento
unipolar utilizar a esa capacidad y ese
poder en el mundo para expandir la
democracia hay dos teorías distintas una
de Johnny kenberry que nos diría que es
precisamente ese imperialismo yanqui el
que motivó la presencia y otros como el
profesor nos dirían que no que era una
intención de expandir la Democracia
porque piensan pensaban que la
democracia es un bien que debe ser
universal que todo el mundo tiene
derecho a la democracia y que hay unos
Tiranos en el mundo que están
yendo en contra del interés de su gente
y que por tanto es necesario una
intervención militar para poder liberar
a esos pueblos de esos Tiranos Además de
que se hace una errónea un erróneo
paralelismo entre estabilidad y
democracia o democracia y riqueza
ahora le doy la palabra a José Antonio
en la ciudad de San Sebastián en el
norte de España José Antonio Gracias por
estar con nosotros también Bienvenido al
programa y quiero conocer su opinión que
deja 20 años después esta guerra en Irak
Cuál es su balance bienvenido
Muchas gracias Es usted muy amable
agradezco mucho a un canal de propiedad
pública francesa no y quiero decir que
el presidente shirak francesa hace 20
años no se equivocó al negar todo apoyo
a esta operación militar que despreció
el derecho internacional
y cuyas consecuencias son exactamente la
que los organizadores de esa guerra
querían es decir destruir el estado
iraquí que ya estaba realmente muy
golpeado después de años de guerras y de
una política realmente bien equivocada
de San José Inn pero que en los 70
apuntaba como la potencia más importante
de una nación árabe también en
construcción las autoridades Entonces
nacionalizan el petróleo
organizan el regadío de los ríos Tigris
y éufrates inician un proceso de
modernización de industrialización de
extensión de la educación Universitaria
saca de una situación de atraso a Irak Y
de lo que se trataba fundamentalmente
por parte de los Estados Unidos del
Reino Unido que había creado la
monarquía iraquí derribada por el pueblo
iraquí el año 58 y también el interés de
Israel fue conseguido es decir hacer hoy
20 años después unidad postrado me ha
gustado mucho la presentación que han
hecho ustedes me parece muy equilibrada
objetiva
desapasionada en la constatación de que
Irak es un país prácticamente
inexistente no tiene desde luego el
nivel de Caos letal de Libia en el norte
de África después de la intervención de
la otan pero es un país descompuesto que
no ha cumplido las expectativas que se
pensaba en los años 70 que
esperaba el mismo pueblo y de aquí que
puso al servicio de su desarrollo la
gran capacidad petrolera que tiene no
único es un país con muchas dificultades
José Antonio continuó con usted para
hacer la ronda la inversa y 20 años
después tal vez cuando se hace análisis
y evaluación de lo que fue ese conflicto
esa invasión Y esa guerra al país sobre
el que cae la mayor cantidad de
acusaciones y señalamientos pues es
Estados Unidos porque era el país que
lideraba hasta coalición internacional
también están involucrados como usted lo
decía el Reino Unido y también España
que también tomó parte de esta de esta
operación para darse un poco más de
visibilidad internacional por lo menos
así lo ha dicho en reiteradas ocasiones
el entonces presidente de gobierno José
María aznart qué es lo que queda esa
imagen de Estados Unidos 20 años después
de estas acciones militares allí de lo
que costó para el pueblo ir aquí recibir
esta invasión Y estos ocho años de
guerra Cuál es la percepción de Estados
Unidos hoy en día después de este
conflicto
mire queda simbólica Prácticamente la
imagen del secretario de estado
norteamericano Colin Powell que engañó a
la humanidad entera a la asamblea
general de las Naciones Unidas agitando
unos tubitos con no se sabe que líquido
en su interior que sobre los que se
justificó una agresión Bárbara que
también Fuentes equilibradas señalan en
un saldo de un millón de Muertos
acusaciones falsas organizadas por el
gobierno de Entonces el señor Bush no
había armas de destrucción masiva Cómo
había declarado además el capitán El
oficial de los Marines norteamericanos
muy famoso en Estados Unidos Scott Rider
Scott Rider que después de Investigar
sobre el terreno clamó al mundo y a su
gobierno la inexistencia de armas de
destrucción masiva pero ya el gobierno
conservador de Bush y de Powell había
decido destruir iraco culminar la
destrucción de ira k y lo que quedó es
una imagen absolutamente deteriorada y
reparablemente deteriorada del respeto
de los Estados Unidos al derecho
internacional a las Naciones Unidas y a
la paz en el mundo no Andrés su opinión
sobre esta imagen de Estados Unidos años
después coincide usted con lo que dice
José Antonio Cuál es su percepción
vamos a ver yo yo creo que es muy
importante que nosotros aprendamos a
entender las relaciones internacionales
desde un punto de vista realista es
decir el derecho internacional que tanto
repetimos
es a nivel teórico
Interesante pero a nivel práctico no lo
es al final la fuerza es lo más
importante no Entonces cuando se tiene
la fuerza no se necesita el derecho
internacional público y lo hemos visto a
lo largo de la historia y evidentemente
como vuelvo a repetir Estados Unidos
estaba el momento unipolar Entonces
podía hacer lo que quisiera en el mundo
no hubo ninguna consecuencia
a la invasión de Irak daba igual lo que
dijera la asamblea de las Naciones
Unidas y daba igual lo que dijera el
consejo de seguridad de las Naciones
Unidas entonces
que el hecho de que se llegara con una
mentira tampoco es la primera vez que
ocurre en la historia de las relaciones
internacionales de hecho sabemos que es
muy común no digo con esto que sea menos
grave digo que es simplemente un hecho
que vuelve a ocurrir y y es muy
importante que en las democracias
nosotros tengamos ciudadanos formados
que entiendan Cuáles son los riesgos de
emprender ese tipo de acciones y como
digo tremendamente ideologizadas mi
compañera ha utilizado el término
conservador no estoy muy de acuerdo Yo
creo que es un es más liberal que
conservador yo creo que desde un punto
de vista conservador lo interesante
hubiera sido cooperar con el régimen de
Adán que por supuesto No era perfecto
Por supuesto que había problemas graves
y que había violaciones de los Derechos
Humanos por supuesto pero morían
muchísimas menos personas y había menos
violaciones de los Derechos Humanos
durante el régimen que después del
régimen por lo tanto nos hemos
equivocado
Andrés continuo con usted usted habla de
lo que trajo esta decisión de Estados
Unidos en un mundo en donde Estados
Unidos lideraba Prácticamente la escena
internacional hoy 20 años después puede
haber algún tipo de condena a Estados
Unidos y a quienes hacían parte de ese
gobierno del presidente George Bush que
tomaron la decisión de llevar a cabo
esta invasión a través de esta coalición
internacional o eso ya se perdió en los
libros de historia en el pasado y estas
personas Nunca van a pagar por el
derramamiento de sangre que hubo en Irak
Mira hay un jurista Romano de hace 2000
años ulpiano que dijo aquello de
quadpring y Black with leguizabeth
vigoren aquello que quiere el príncipe
tiene valor normativo nunca nunca
piensen en lo técnico el derecho
internacional es una cuestión técnica lo
que importa es la política si Estados
Unidos pierde totalmente el poder en el
mundo y llegan otras potencias que
redistribuyen ese poder utilizarán los
medios jurídicos para que haya
consecuencias jurídicas en todo lo que a
ellos les interese pero olvídense de la
justicia ni cuando Estados Unidos
mandaba al mundo ni cuando otros lo
manden porque lo único que va a importar
es el interés de esas naciones si ellos
tienen si esas otras naciones llegan
alguna vez a tener el poder y les
interesa políticamente atacar a Estados
Unidos a través de perseguir
potenciales delitos que hayan cometido
en ese momento lo harán
José Antonio su opinión sobre esto
Estados Unidos algún día será condenado
por esta invasión
Bueno estamos ante la decadencia del
imperialismo norteamericano
este tipo de cadencias no se hacen de un
día para otro hay que recordar que los
Estados Unidos tienen una capacidad
militar de escala universal y
efectivamente es cierto el derecho
internacional es lo que caracteriza una
civilización humana avanzada la
violación del derecho internacional es
lo que caracteriza a los imperios
sanguinarios y decadentes que ponen en
peligro la existencia del planeta por
favorecer la posición de privilegio de
las élites que en el caso de Irak lo que
querían era quedarse con el petróleo
aniquilar la capacidad de independencia
de ese país y de servir de referencia a
la nación árabe no entonces habrá un
juicio de núremberg real o histórico
porque lo que Es evidente que si en el
código penal que se nos aplica a los
mortales simples los ciudadanos el
delito de asesinato no prescribe nunca
Cómo va a prescribir histórica ni
prácticamente el asesinato de un millón
de iraquíes inocentes bajo
responsabilidad del gobierno bueno no le
llame conservador ya me Lee republicano
es igual el que representa la oligarquía
norteamericana
encontrándose en estos momentos el mundo
ante precisamente la tesitura de
construir un mundo multipolar en el que
barbaries
inauditas como la destrucción de Irak
probablemente el hecho más sangriento de
lo que llevamos del siglo XXI vuelve a
repetirse jamás nunca Y eso está muy
presente la memoria de los pueblos de la
gran mayoría de la humanidad
eh José Antonio es en cuanto a Estados
Unidos 20 años después que hay de Irak
ya mencionábamos estas divisiones que
hay estos problemas que hay para la
construcción del estado como tal para
poder afrontar las situaciones que se le
presentan en el día a día cualquier país
una sociedad dividida Refugio de
supuestos terroristas ante los ojos o
por lo menos desde la mirada occidental
también con problemas con las minorías
un país muy complejo para cohesionar
como nación Cuál es el
la importancia del rol de Irak en la
actualidad entendiendo estas
dificultades que tiene
me lo pregunta a mí verdad sí José
Antonio adelante hemos hablado de la
pérdida de un millón de Vidas pero es
que hay otra pérdida mayor que es el de
la cohesión de un país milenario que se
construyó sobre la base de lo que tenía
en común la tradición colonialista
occidental representada por los Estados
Unidos
buscaba Precisamente lo contrario a
través de una política de cuotas dividir
la sociedad iraquí en comunidades que
tenían mucho en común hay una gran
mayoría que es musulmana los musulmanes
tienen un Corán común y me he encontrado
con muchos musulmanes que dicen nosotros
hasta hace pocos años nadie le importaba
Quién era sí quién era
su niño Quién era lo que fuese y lo
mismo respecto a las identidades étnicas
una de las grandes responsabilidades de
los Estados Unidos es haber creado un
país en guerra civil permanente no
Y eso es muy difícil que se pueda
recomponer porque ha corrido mucha
sangre entre esa gente y además hay
mucha responsabilidad yo no voy a
justificar a Sadam y a sus crímenes uno
de sus crímenes más graves fue atacar a
Irán y crear una guerra entre hermanos
de la misma región Por cierto también
alentada por los Estados Unidos Pero
entonces había más posibilidades de
construir una entidad bastante
cohesionada sabiendo que la gran mayoría
de los pueblos del mundo tienen
complejidades pero los pueblos superan
las complejidades y en Oriente medio la
han superado milenariamente recordemos
que el origen de la humanidad es esa
Región del mundo precisamente no Andrés
su opinión Cuál es la importancia de
este eslabón en el escenario
internacional llamado Irak Irak es
importante hoy en día en la escena
internacional 20 años después de esta
guerra
miren yo tengo una visión mucho menos
edulcorada yo he vivido tres años en ira
que he sido el director del departamento
de dos universidades de ciencia política
y relaciones internacionales y yo creo
que la cohesión de Irak no tenía nada
que ver con los Hermanos la cuestión de
Irak tenía que ver con un líder que
ejercía la fuerza y se aseguraba de que
nadie cuestionara su poder y de hecho yo
no creo que hubiera cohesión étnica el
presidente Sam gasea a los kurdos en
marzo del 88 en lo que hoy es el
gobernador de jalab Ya no creo que se
trataran entre hermanos y no creo que
occidente fuera el que dividió Irak
occidente cometió una estupidez enorme
porque no sabía lo que estaba haciendo
no tenía ni idea de lo que estaba
haciendo con ese objetivo democratizar
el país pero que tratara de dividir y
que el sistema de cuotas divida a mí me
parece que que eso no es para nada
cierto yo creo que lo que está claro es
que hay un profundo desconocimiento de
la realidad de oriente medio y también
Creo que hay una visión
occidental que critica mucho la visión
accidental pensando precisamente
que ellos son muy buenos y quieren vivir
como hermanos y que nosotros somos el
eje disruptor el presidente Sam llamaba
a homeni homeeny
El anticristo Entonces no no creo desde
luego que que esa guerra Proxy de Irán
contra Irak que al final era una guerra
entre Estados Unidos y la unión
soviética entre 1980 y 1988 tuviera nada
que ver con una lucha entre hermanos
eras una lucha contra enemigos
milenarios de de la nación árabe contra
el Imperio persa y en cuanto a Cuál es
la función de iraku y en el mundo dirá
que es una colonia iraní en todos los
niveles en el nivel de seguridad en el
nivel económico en el nivel político en
el nivel cultural en el nivel social y
tenemos un termómetro fantástico para
entenderlo que son precisamente los
kurdos
desde hace cinco años se podía ver
perfectamente que undistán libre somos
independientes kurdistán libre sigan
ustedes las noticias de kurdistán nadie
utiliza la palabra kurdistán por qué
Porque es una colonia iraní Los iraníes
tienen muchísimo miedo como Es lógico a
que los kurdos tengan un tipo de
soberanía sobre la zona un tipo de
Independencia porque en Irán también hay
kurdos y no tiene una visión
particularmente buena de los kurdos ni
los turcos ni los ni los ni los sirios
ni los iraquíes ni los iraníes ni ni
nadie no Sí esa era una de las preguntas
que le quería hacer Andrés sobre los
cursos hoy en día que abarcan buena
parte del Norte del territorio iraquí
tienen una autonomía tienen un
parlamento propio Un gobierno propio Y
gozan de cierta prosperidad a nivel
económico pero pero de acuerdo a lo que
usted dice los vecinos no están muy de
acuerdo con esa con esa cierta autonomía
o prosperidad que están teniendo los
kurdos después de estos conflictos y que
de cara al futuro puedan llegar a tener
un estado soberano eso se descarta por
completo Andrés
eso lo descartaron ellos los propios
curdos en el momento en el que
decidieron que cada que cada familia iba
a tener una milicia y un grupo armado y
un partido político cuando nosotros no
sienta hablamos de los kurdos alguien
puede llegar a pensar que son un grupo
unitario lo único que tienen en común
son los genes tenemos el partido
democrático del kurdistán de los barsani
tenemos el partido
de los talavani y tenemos grupúsculos
pequeñísimos que lo único que tienen en
común es un parche en el uniforme una
bandera kurda pero que siempre se han
atacado que se siguen atacando que de
hecho en la propia en la propia
dictadura al presidente Sadam era Aliado
de los barsani atacaban a los talabani
que es una de las cosas en la que
tenemos muchísimos testimonios gráficos
simplemente Somos unos Tremendos
desconocedores de la historia de oriente
medio de África y nos encanta dar
nuestra sin tener ni idea de Cuál es el
verdadero problema pensando eso que que
son mejores que nosotros que nosotros
intervenimos en el mundo y que y que
tenemos un plan muy diabólico cuando en
el fondo el resultado es que nosotros
somos muy tontos y no los entendemos
José Antonio Cómo entender entonces la
región hoy en día 20 años después Qué
papel juega entonces Irak en esta región
en donde hay dos actores muy importantes
que recientemente restablecieron en
relaciones que son Arabia Saudita e Irán
Irán sobre todo es un actor importante
en este conflicto
aquí se movieron mucho las piezas
después de esta guerra 20 años después
la región se reconfiguró como lo ve
usted
claro
precisamente
perdió toda la gravitación que iba a
tener
desarrollar
se las Muse desarrollaban en los años 70
en los años 70 hubo un gobierno de
unidad nacional con una mayoría del
partido base
al que todavía no había llegado a su
máxima dirección si no su tío pero
también estaba el partido comunista que
por cierto había sido
durísimamente atacado por el partido
base en la década anterior pero
consiguieron formar ese gobierno de
unidad nacional al que se incorporó el
partido de barsani es decir no había
durante un cierto tiempo
una tradición de violencia para resolver
los problemas políticos que
lamentablemente ha sido una de las
tradiciones iraquíes que se aplazó o se
congeló o se moderó en aquella época de
frente nacional progresista que
nacionaliza el petróleo y que permite
crear el horizonte de un Irak próspero
que hoy hubiese tenido una enorme
gravitación sobre la zona como el eje
central de la nación árabe desplazando a
las monarquías del Golfo muy
estrechamente aliadas a las potencias
occidentales colonialistas Porque además
son en gran medida creaciones del Reino
Unido no de su graciosa majestad
británica Irak fue destruido como lo
planteaban las potencias atacantes
vuelvo a insistir Francia no intervino
en ese desastre sí ha intervenido
Lamentablemente en el desastres sirio
pero ante un Irak en el que es que eso y
un escenario de combate entre los
intereses por un lado de Irán por otro
lado de los occidentales con la
herramienta del islam o terrorismo
siempre presente ahí hay que reconocer
que al qaeda proviene de la operación
ciclón de la Sienna Afganistán
edades proviene de al qaeda ha quedado
desaparecida y hay un con la
intervención de China ha tenido que ser
China la que ponga de acuerdo a la
monarquía saudí con la República
islámica de Irán para crear un eje allí
de una cierta contención
entre estas dos grandes potencias que
son las emergentes en esa zona del mundo
ya vamos a hablar del papel de china
Porque es importante Quiero conocer la
opinión de Andrés sobre el rol que juega
Irán y Arabia Saudita en todo este
ajedrez
bien un apunte si me lo permiten de lo
anterior es un error enorme hablar de
Irak y progresismo o hablar de Irak y
unidad nacional es que estamos hablando
de un planeta distinto siempre que
metemos lexico occidental de la ciencia
política occidental ya hemos destruido
toda posibilidad de un análisis serio y
real sobre sobre el país pero el rol de
China china Está tratando de colonizar
El Mundo de la manera China y para eso
necesita jugar todas las piezas en el
planeta Y entonces evidentemente a China
no le interesa Cuál es el régimen
político ni económico que tienen las
naciones Busca solamente Cuál es su
entrada de interés nacional Entonces
evidentemente eso es muy sencillo en el
momento que estamos viviendo sobre todo
también el contexto de la Guerra de
Ucrania porque permite a China mostrarse
como una alternativa viable
Pero obviamente con el mismo objetivo
que tiene cualquier nación en el mundo
que piense incluido la francesa y por
eso Tenemos tantos siglos de Historia La
relaciones internacionales el que
podemos juzgar el comportamiento de
Francia es decir tratar de expandir su
poder y mantener y expandir en ese
sentido evidentemente Irán es un hegemon
regional entonces china necesita que su
estrategia esté de alguna manera sea
compatible con la estrategia iraní
porque no quiere entrar en un conflicto
directo con Irán mucho menos ahora en
ese momento de expansión y evidentemente
es en ese contexto en el que la
República popular china fomenta un
entendimiento entre los dos grandes
rivales del mundo
musulmán que son el reino Arabia saudí y
la República es la Micaela
Esto entonces reconfigura las cargas
allí en la región después de estos 20
años en donde había cierta cierto
digamos desorden donde las monarquías se
habían Aliado más con occidente y había
cierta tensión en la zona ahora con este
este acercamiento que hace china entre
estos dos países de suma importancia en
la región se reequilibran entonces las
cargas Andrés muy puntual por favor se
dan ustedes cuenta de que el momento de
mayor estabilidad es siempre cuando hay
un actor que es muy poderoso Entonces en
ese momento se da un momento de
estabilidad nos pasa en el Irak de Sadam
tiene el monopolio de la violencia y es
por tanto por lo que tenemos una gran
estabilidad y China está buscando una
estabilidad yo no soy muy optimista
sobre las relaciones entre Irán y Arabia
saudívar ya no ir bien no van a ir bien
pero nos está mostrando que China tiene
mucho interés de que vayan bien porque
necesita Buscar un mundo Pacífico en el
que ellos manden desterrando totalmente
ese poder occidental José Antonio paso a
preguntarle por algo que ustedes han
comentado a lo largo de este programa y
es ese modelo de democracia
occidental tal parece viendo no
solamente El ejemplo de Irak 20 años
después sino también Libia túnez en
cierta forma y la misma Siria Tal parece
que este modelo o por lo menos occidente
no ha podido entender que esto no es un
modelo que puede hacer y puesto en todas
partes del mundo y que por ejemplo en el
mundo musulmán allí en medio oriente no
les interesa necesariamente tener una
democracia como se entiende desde
occidente en su forma y estilo pueden
instaurar un modelo que les funciona de
acuerdo a su idiosincrasia a su forma de
entender la política y un estado O usted
qué piensa
realmente me gusta mucho una pregunta
tan inteligente como la que me planteé
usted
no colonial occidental de imponer su
propio modelo Como si fuese el único
capaz de funcionar en todas las partes
del mundo no en una sociedad tribal
[Música]
que nos cuesta bastante
entenderla No rige la
el fundamento de un hombre un voto
Aunque el principio nacido de la
Revolución Francesa de la soberanía del
pueblo sí que rige universalmente y
también en el mundo árabe Lo que pasa
que no se podrá articular en una manera
partidocrática que no representa los
intereses de la sociedad si nos
intereses de determinadas élites y
muchas veces de élites extranjeras es
decir yo creo que si no hubiese habido
la destrucción de Irak por parte de los
bárbaros occidentales Herederos de los
cruzados occidentales probablemente Irak
hubiese sabido
encontrar la manera de articular las
formas tradicionales de organizarse con
las aportaciones que son universales de
respecto a la soberanía que tiene la
población de tener la titularidad del
Poder y de ejercer ese poder en función
de sus intereses de su cultura y de su
idiosincrasia le guste o no al viejo amo
colonial occidental No
desde su opinión sobre este tema
a mí me parece que hablar en Irak de
Revolución francesa y algo y conectarlo
con Revolución Francesa es un error
total en el Irak de Sadam y en la región
la fuerza no se tiene por la población
la población no le interesa a nadie se
busca un interés que está por encima de
esa población Entonces se busca un líder
fuerte que gobierne primero para él y
luego para el pueblo en ese orden que es
lo que hemos visto no lo estoy
criticando es una es una realidad pero
no interesa lo que diga la población irá
que era un país de mayoría gobernada por
un sunín no no tiene nada que ver con un
hombre un voto en absoluto ni ni ningún
tipo de nada que nosotros podamos
conectar con la civilización occidental
y también me gustaría hacer un
comentario importante el Irak de saddán
tenía dos millones de cristianos
Entonces cuando hacemos comentarios
sobre los cruzados Oigan Hay comunidades
católicas en Irak que son del siglo 1 y
que tiene una grandísima importancia
Entonces no no es el cristianismo contra
el islam es la estupidez occidental
contra una realidad muy compleja que se
llama
y que tenemos que entender y que es muy
difícil de entender desde occidente
Entonces lo primero quitar desaprender
quitarnos todo lo que creemos que
sabemos sobre Oriente para poder empezar
a entender desde cero cuáles son sus
cosas es muy difícil porque todos
venimos formados desde la universidad
con un esquema de lo que es el mundo de
Cómo es el mundo pero llegar y se lo
digo por mi propia experiencia personal
cuando yo llegué a Irak me di cuenta de
que no sabía absolutamente nada de
oriente medio norte de África y llegué
como profesor titular de relaciones
internacionales muy diciente con este
tema de la religión que usted menciona
Andrés es justamente la visita del Papa
Francisco aidac donde estuvo haciendo
allí una visita por unos días para la
comunidad cristiana o católica que que
reside en ese país que Bueno usted lo
dice dos millones de personas
la religión católica en medio de un
mundo completamente rodeado de países
musulmanes y una herencia musulmana
ancestral vamos llegando ya al bloque
final de el programa vamos llegando a la
última parte dos preguntas para el
cierre y quiero que sean muy concretos
por favor para poderlas hacer las dos
Andrés rápidamente este guión de Irak se
está repitiendo en este momento en
Ucrania con diferentes actores es más o
menos el mismo libreto de la misma
película La misma cinta como lo ve Pero
por supuesto porque no sabemos hacer
otra cosa porque vemos el mundo de una
determinada manera nuestra población del
mundo de una determinada manera nuestras
élites viene el mundo de una determinada
manera y Parece ser que vemos cerca el
colapso que desde luego ya lo veo muy
cerca o no vamos a ser capaces de
cambiar José Antonio rápidamente Ucrania
2 2.0 podemos decir que es un Irak 2.0
perdón
bueno Ucrania es el límite de la lógica
norteamericana de imponer su voluntad a
los pueblos de una manera impune Ucrania
lo dicen los norteamericanos tenía que
ser la base de agresión a Rusia para
destruir a Rusia como lo han hecho con
Irak con Serbia con Libia le guste o no
al Señor profesor de relaciones
internacionales que no ha hecho más que
faltarme al respeto yo no le falto a él
al respeto pero le voy a decir que en
Ucrania están haciendo un mundo
multipolar con respeto al derecho
internacional que le vuelvo a decir es
el instrumento de las Naciones del mundo
para evitar un holocausto nuclear
que se va a producir si se sigue
respetando el derecho internacional Como
lo hicieron los Estados Unidos en Irak
José Antonio rápidamente me queda un
minuto para finalizar el programa la
conclusión Irak hacia el futuro un Irak
en paz unidad dividido fragmentado o
nuevamente como un terreno de batalla
muy puntual José Antonio por favor de
Juan transpara al cierre
Irak tiene las herramientas culturales
suficientes el suficiente pasado la
suficiente bagaje cultural para hacer su
propia autocrítica y sobre la base de la
soberanía mirar al futuro en paz sí
Andrés su conclusión
irá que está completamente destruido no
tiene ninguna identidad actualmente es
una mera Colonia y les va a costar mucho
Si alguna vez lo consiguen poder
reconstruir el país Andrés José Antonio
Muchas gracias por haber estado con
nosotros aquí en el debate de France 24
es todo por el día de hoy Muchas gracias
por su sintonía En nombre del equipo
técnico Les agradecemos haber estado con
nosotros la producción del programa
estuvo a cargo de Laura garzón y de
Jennifer Guevara y la producción de
invitados estuvo a cargo de Tania
Herrera Pueden seguir dejando sus
comentarios a través de las redes
sociales sigan con nosotros
[Música]